so basically one of the major things
that I've worked on at Wolfram research
since I started about a year ago is the
backend code for the e IW l api that the
grades d exercises that go with the book
so as an example of what they look like
in case you haven't seen it but i'm
guessing most people here have this is
how it starts out if you want is this
site here and try some of these out as
we go but basically i'm going to be
talking about how it works briefly and
some of the cool things you can do with
the Wolfram language basically make this
type of thing possible so anyways you've
got these exercises online that go with
the book and they're pretty easy so this
seems like a really simple problem I was
asked to write an API they could take
basically user programs compare that to
an answer key and decide whether or not
they got the right answer so compute 1 +
2 + 3 easy got it correct it marks it
when it's wrong as well so doing pretty
good so far so one of the questions you
have to ask is how do you decide when a
program is correct given some answer key
you could look at the actual structure
of the code what they've written is the
program identical to the one in the
answer key so in that first example it
asks you to compute 1 + 2 + 3 if that's
your definition of equivalence then only
1 + 2 + 3 will give you the right answer
if you do it backwards not going to work
another way of determining equivalents
which is probably the intuitive way
people would think of doing this is you
just evaluate code and so you get to the
output obviously that makes sense here
it'll
things that are equal it makes sense for
arithmetic but there are some things you
need to be concerned about when using
that approach especially when you're
running a publicly available API in the
cloud so one of the questions is you
have to somewhat arbitrarily decide what
should be considered correct and which
shouldn't be this a lot of gray area
here so 1 + 2 + 3 gives the same output
as echo of 1 + 2 + 3 is it are they the
same program though do they do the same
thing so that's one of the things you
have to keep in mind obviously the next
one those are two very very different
expressions yet they produce the same
output just to make sure you guys
believe me there's other things you have
to worry about what if somebody submits
their program for that first exercise
delete all the important files that run
the API do you want to run that how do
you how do you know that it's okay to
run then you have things like random
values that's where things get pretty
tricky you can seed the random number
generator that's that's one way of
addressing that but that doesn't that
doesn't address all cases because should
these be considered equivalent if you
take ten random integers up to ten and
then you do the same thing then reverse
them is that an equivalent program
they're being sampled from the same
distribution but you're going to get
different answers but they're just as
good right in some sense so yeah it is
it is a hard problem but the good news
is it mostly works if you throw a whole
lot of stuff at it here's an example of
some of the things
where it does handle those types of
problems i was talking about so for
example that echo there in that pie
chart that none of that will ever show
up in the actual output but it's it's
generating a side effect which alters
the behavior of the program the third
one also has that but it's not actually
evaluated because the hold so that does
generate the the same thing I use a bit
more complicated example in the next one
but you probably don't want me to go
through each of them to see why they're
correct or incorrect but the fun example
is the second to last one and I think
it's pretty neat that it can figure that
out so how does it work that's what I
want to talk about I believe I can do
that
ok
okay so the two types of equivalents
that I already mentioned the basically
the simple and straightforward methods
are looking at the input of the or the
original form of the code i should say
and the others just evaluate them and
see if they get the same thing there's a
lot more you can do here though as an
example that most people probably
familiar with is another form of
equivalence the testing equality and for
mathematical values so if you do equals
instead of same queue for example that's
that's totally different definition of
equivalence and that's doing all kinds
of neat stuff to figure that out and
that's kind of what this is doing it's
sort of basically coming up with an
equals function for arbitrary programs
very small programs for these exercises
which is why this is actually even
feasible so next one is equivalent by
definition the symbol red for example
that's equivalent to RGB color 100 how
do we know because we can just look so
we know when we evaluate that they're
gonna that's going to be equivalent
they're going to evaluate the same thing
so you would think the size and kind of
throughout the alignment here and I
don't know how to use a neck so I'm just
going to leave it that way but these are
otherwise the same expression except for
the red in the RGB color so what happens
when I evaluate that do you think when I
compare them
what do you think they're the same thing
right Holden hot
I just looped around again but here's
why and this actually shows up a lot
this is one of those types of problems
where at first you look at it and be
like oh just evaluated you get the same
result no big deal you spend two or
three days working on this and you're
done deploy it move on to the next thing
but now the more you look at it the
weirder gets and the more difficult to
get so when you're dealing with these
dynamic boxes for example with or
dynamic modules with their own local
variables you've got that in it it's
otherwise the exact same expression
except you've got these local variables
that get named differently so you can't
just you can't run same queue on either
the input in this case because that RGB
color and red difference and you can't
do it on the output but they are the
same I think everyone here would agree
that they're doing the same thing in any
way that we would care about so what we
can do in this example because there's
only one difference here and we have a
definition saying that these are exactly
the same just replace it easy enough and
this is kind of the the fundamental part
of how the the grading system works the
why I would say about half of them are
just just evaluated and see if they're
the same so the ones that like 1 + 2 + 3
it's just going to evaluate it doesn't
care it's going to do it the simple way
but there are so many examples in those
exercises we have things like dynamic
modules you have things like cloud
deploy and things that you're just
generally not going to be able to run in
an API and the cloud like arbitrarily so
it takes a lot of magic I guess
so coming up with these rules for
example red and RGB color that that's an
easy one sorry my computer keeps not
moving I just go back a page
no that's a whole whole cell opener I
did not know that okay so one of the
things to make this easier is automate
as much as possible discover these rules
without having to manually figure out
all these different things like you
don't have to look for all the colors
you just get the list of all names you
make sure they're not read protected so
those you're not going to be able to
look at the definition anyway and it's
going to throw hours at you and you just
look for rules in this example I'm just
looking for RGB color you can do this
for anything else fairly in fact you
probably do want to make it more general
but this is an example of how you can
get all the rules for the named colors
and now I can use this set of rules to
eliminate any instance of these named
colors in any expression and they show
up a lot in these the awl exercises so
that's what that's doing is however many
of there are there like maybe 20 or so
that's basically reducing the size of
the language by about 20 symbols which
that's a very very small slice of what's
there but the more you can do that these
with the small of the languages the
smaller the set of patterns you have to
consider for these types of rules you
want to do so trying to find like these
examples we can knock out a whole bunch
of symbols at once that really helps you
out in the long run and obviously that
is going to work for that example from
earlier you don't actually have to
evaluate it there are also methods we
could evaluate them and then renormalize
the variables test but just replacing
the right i think is easier for this one
so equivalence by definition that's just
quite literally look at the definition
of symbols and see what they're the same
s and just replaced them is necessary
and in fact when you get the definition
of symbols like with own values or down
values things like that
you're getting a list of replacement
rules because that's how the language
fundamentally works it's a it's a term
rewriting system you've got basically a
set of rules that tells you how to
transform expressions and it does its
thing fortunately you can also override
much of that all right propositional
equivalents so there are other things in
fact the vast majority of the
transformations that are useful for this
that you're not going to be able to
discover through definition it's a lot
of kernel functions for example that you
can't just check to see if they're doing
the same thing so for example any range
can be expressed as a table so however
you have the argument set up and this is
assuming that you're not interested in a
like range of a string for example
because that's technically valid
expression but it's going to generate a
message and it's not useful for anything
so
see how those are the same and that's
how we can express that that equivalence
as a replacement rule so taking any
range with its arguments and like I said
this is assuming you don't care about
ridiculous forms with like range of like
300 arguments or whatever so obviously
that's not very useful no one's going to
do it so we here we have another example
where the inputs are different and
because of those random integers in
there the output will end up being
different too but just using this rule
here that's an example of the different
output but you just you don't even have
to evaluate it you just use your rule
which I mean it doesn't seem like you
can get very far with like one or two at
a time and this is going backwards again
help them not go to computer
okay so yeah so table and range are two
extremely common functions in the
language and like I was mentioning
before being able to reduce the size of
the language not just in the number of
symbols you're dealing with but the
number of patterns in a sense that you
would want to deal with even though
they're pretty much all infinite for the
ones we're interested in but going the
other way around instead of converting
ranges to tables would we be interested
in convert and would we be interested in
converting tables two ranges weekend for
some of them but not all of them like
this this table here how would you
generate that with right and she just
can't so table in a sense is a larger
class of possible expressions than range
all ranges can be mapped into tables but
not the other way around and that's
that's an important thing to keep in
mind one year you're coming up with
these rules so here's an example of you
know an ugly rule that does what I just
said which I wouldn't recommend going
that direction and you call it you could
also have done the same thing with the
the RGB color and red but think about
that that doesn't go the other way as
easily so if you like if we were looking
at patterns like this obviously those
aren't all going to be able to map to
read
so with what I was saying before about
how one represents a larger class of
expressions than the other the same is
true with in the the types of tables you
might see where you could have these
these iterative forms where you just
have your two integers so it's your your
minimum value and then your maximum
value that it goes to but those can also
be represented by this class of patterns
as well just by that last integer being
a one but not all these four argument
lists here can be represented by the
three argument form so it's it's it's
defining a gradient that you really want
to follow where you're mapping in the
direction where things will always fit
so when you're considering these
replacement rules you also have to make
sure you don't do things like create
infinite loops so if you had one rule in
there where it's you know mapping these
symbol integer integer to these three
integers down here and he had another
one going the other way you're not going
to get very far with trying to reduce
expressions with that so and this is
this is the rule that does what I just
mentioned putting the gap one there will
eliminate all tables of this form you
don't have to worry about that pattern
anymore so what this is doing is as you
come up with these rules wait were you
mapping things into these I guess larger
equivalence classes you're you basically
following a gradient and the idea is as
you keep transforming these expressions
if they're equivalent without having to
evaluate them if you have a nice set of
rules they should converge at some point
because they're they're tracing these
transformations which by themselves
represent equivalent
relations and if you're preserving the
expression as you go and they do
eventually converge then you know that
their original forms should also be
equivalent but there are some of the
issues
so for example here's another one where
you can take a symbol and an integer of
table and also map it to that for
argument list iterator so that's also
eliminating all these these forms of
tables here that you don't worry about
anymore but one of the things you have
to keep in mind it's very significant
that you make sure you match your
patterns to the appropriate head so if i
didn't have integer here that could
potentially grab a list that represent
something totally different and it's a
totally valid thing to do so here's
where things get difficult this one here
are this n that's not going to match
this when it's in this held form here
because that's not an integer so the
pattern matcher is not going to see that
as an integer even though I know it's
going to be an integer during evaluation
pattern matcher doesn't know that so I
come up with some really big complicated
looking rules where it's looking for
nested tables and things like that and
things start running really slow if you
start taking that approach and it's
pretty hard to avoid this type of thing
running slow to begin with but doing
that would just be a disaster so
and that's no good we were unable to
eliminate that to argument form of the
sitter writer even though we have the
rule to do so it just can't recognize it
this is what we want to see that's the
desired goal that's what i call the
canonical form of this expression having
these four arguments / iterator here if
assuming their actual numeric values and
not a list so I kinda hesitant called it
a type system because it doesn't do all
the things one would normally associate
with type system so it's not going to do
like all the need static analysis stuff
it's basically all it does is it looks
for expected patterns so it's basically
a way of propagating patterns lower into
the expression without evaluating it to
basically assign what you which you know
that it's going to match and that's all
in this package here and with any luck
because I'm not on a branch that I think
is stable okay yeah it did work neat so
it looks different I did that to
basically save myself time in the long
run because these are big ugly things
otherwise but this this handles that
that issue that was in the way so for
example actually the intermediate form
appears as the one that would have had
that example but
I'm going to grab that one
so there we go it's it's currently not
in a form that you would usually want
because those aren't aren't symbols
anymore tho those are that that kind of
type rapper where it really just
neat
alright well I lost that of the table
but you believe me right reload that oh
and that's this thing that I lost before
they don't want to oh no I think she'd
be fine now yeah that's for other stuff
but this is a way to take these three
expressions which are very different
from each other in this case maybe it's
not the best example because these would
all evaluate to the same thing that's
all deterministic here probably should
have put random numbers in there or
something but just to show you that
without evaluating it I can determine
that they're the same thing and that's
type system and I should rename it
because it's really not a type system
because this is just the expected
pattern that I care about it's not
integer as a type because you can also
have a form where has you know blank
sequence or blank null sequence things
like that and that's also valid thing so
what does mentioning earlier about how
equivalent expressions should converge
at some point during these these
transformations you can kind of
visualize that so you can see exactly
one for example well first thing it does
is it it normalizes these names because
if this is tabled J for example how
would you compare that to the iterator
with I so this is just
more box form stuff so I don't have to
try and hurt my brain reading these
waffle outputs I highly recommend box
forms for anything that you don't want
to look at on a regular basis so here's
what we have first thing normalizes all
names and actually I kind of skipped a
step because the first thing it does is
map this this first outer set of
iterators here to its it's for argument
form it knows automatically sees this as
an integer it can match that one it's
immediately going to expand that is its
first step and so now it has symbols in
here it still can't do anything with
this one doesn't know yet what that's
going to be but now looking at this one
here and it sees that these are all
integers over here it's like ok these
are integer iterators I know that this
one here and I should have made the Box
phone preserve the numbers but oh well
now at this point it knows because these
integers this is going to be an integer
which replaces all occurrences of itself
with that integer so you can kind of see
how this data flow occurs with this
trace here so this sends this integer
pattern down into the nested table and
now in the next step the rules look at
this and be like okay I have a symbol
here now I know this isn't a list now I
know it's an integer even though it's
not your usual integer pattern it's this
this wrapper here but you can you can
still use this these set of rules
written as you normally would in it
it'll convert them to do this and then
you can expand all these out into their
canonical forms even if you have these
nested symbol patterns here's another
example where again I'm using things
that are evaluate the same thing anyway
but I just like tables
so obviously those are all different
from each other while they're held
before they're evaluated but if I gather
them by their canonical form I can see
how many equivalence classes there
actually are and there and each of those
classes are equivalent by this function
i made that says so so trust me on that
one for now but if I release the hold
and and check that verifies it
and this is this is that convergence of
transformations I was talking about
which I hope this eight-year-old
computer can actually do this oh there
we go so the terminal points here on the
graph represent the original expression
so each step like you see in this list
here represents one of these
transformations for each of these
expressions so they all started out
different from each other and they
followed a path through their their
equivalence class so just verifying that
their paths connected in this this space
of expressions is a way of determining
that they're equivalent like the middle
one here you could have determined their
equivalent with hopefully evaluating
them as well without going with full
sequence but it's not super efficient
right now and this also corresponds with
the number of groups that were
equivalent by evaluating and equivalent
by my function here that I promise you
works so that's kind of the bulk of how
the rule system works just taking these
transformation rules and repeatedly
applying them in a specific direction to
reach this canonical form for these
expressions that still doesn't get you
everything though this like I don't like
150 rules or so in the system and it
still doesn't always catch everything
and in fact if you went on those yeah WL
exercises right now just knowing the
language a little bit if you wanted to
find things that it can't catch it might
take you one or two tries if that's what
you deliberately trying to do it's it
only captures like such a small subset
of the language but it works because
yeah WL represents very small subset
language is something like 200 something
functions i think represented in the
book but only a few of them are used
often and
you really only have to make this good
enough because this is an impossible
problem actually in general yep
for like those arithmetic type of
problems its earlier versions it would
actually say in section one for example
if you just put six for the the first
answer now it's it's just going to say
it's correct there was some extra logic
in there to make sure you're in the
spirit of the exercise but it sort of
been kind of more generalized and
there's less ee i ee l specific stuff so
the arithmetic stuff it's just going to
evaluate it and if it gets the same
answer it's same but for the things that
you can't evaluate but you do want to
know about the side effects and this
might not be the best name either
because this isn't just like a don't run
code type of sandbox thing this is more
of a capture side effects and and keep
track of stuff that happens but still
evaluate so it was originally written as
a don't run bad code thing which it's
also what it does but its main purposes
for capturing these side effects and
yeah that is rewritten in this version
so it does more so this is this is what
the output of that expression is so I
can't copy stuff apparently
that's really weird because I haven't
had any issues with that at all maybe
it's this building that's totally
possible right
someone sees me about to copy and paste
something just yell at me so I don't I'm
probably going to anyway though yep
yeah early earlier versions it was very
much focused on doing that so there are
some exercises that say use times and
range or something i don't remember up
top of my head but there are some that
say use these functions it used to
specifically require those to be marked
correct it doesn't currently do that
right now there are things that it still
does that are specific to this like if
you're using functions that don't appear
in the section you're in or before that
and you get it right it's going to say
you got it right you'll be using more
advanced functions and I think the
intent was to eventually eat like
generate a message saying once you move
on to this other section or check out
introduction for programmers that type
of things those more feedback thing but
it does dil still do some of that stuff
where it's looking specifically at I
guess the structure of the book and like
what what comes where
yeah so actually one of the things that
that does occur during the
transformations is there's a particular
batch of rules where it's looking for
like mathematical expressions with like
you know undefined symbols and and also
these like typed integers for example
and it's actually calling simplify on
those when it deems safe to do so and
that that actually is one of the steps
it takes but it does so on much smaller
parts of the expression because it's
pretty hard to keep this thing running
fast so it works for the e IW l stuff
when it's really maybe two or three
lines of code at most you have to deal
with but there definitely are
limitations with how much I can throw on
to it there there are lots of rules and
lots of things I would like to add into
these transformations but they're just
not worth the the performance impact
yeah it's time constraint so yeah it's
it's I don't remember what it set out
right now I think it's probably five
seconds or so but if somebody wants to
compute 1 + 2 + 3 and you know the
weirdest way possible in a hundred lines
if they can do that in five seconds more
power to them and that actually sounds
like a lot of fun to me so I wouldn't
want to restrict that I say if they can
do it under the memory limits under the
time limits go for it yeah so this is
the bit where it so you'll notice the
echo didn't actually evaluate hear it it
ran through this evaluation as if it did
evaluate but it stopped it recorded the
order that these things happen in things
that generate side effects because
that's significant and then it keeps
keeps a record of that like the reason
it has that captured separately would be
like
so that would show up and they'll put it
all but you wouldn't want that
expression to be equivalent to just
range or five because it does do this
extra stuff and I don't know why I just
type that in because this does exactly
the same thing that i want to show you
but it does it does keep track of things
like certain functions will hold their
arguments so you don't want to just pass
those down because this form here
those are just strings there and if this
function here did not have any holding
attributes whatever's left over here is
going to evaluate to make sure it does
propagate those evaluations correctly
this one preserves in the trace or in
what it captures what the forum was but
these aren't all the same because I had
a different value for each of those and
more box form stuff to keep track of
that because that's another big awful
thing to look at if I didn't do that but
you can see how there's quite a bit of
difference here because this one you
don't have to keep track of what the
value of I was at the time that that
print would have evaluated because it
doesn't matter because that that's just
going to evaluate before print even does
anything to it doesn't have any holding
attributes this one on the other hand
has to keep track of a closure that
represents the relevant part of the
state of the evaluation that it needs to
needs to know and again I had the answer
to the thing that I was trying to show
this is not right
I think after I crash to open the wrong
woman
this is a bunch of stuff that i was
thinking of putting in the slides and
most of it i actually did end up doing
that so i'm just going to mention so
these are examples that I put in the
early part of the slides that's already
loaded all right so coat equivalent q is
basically that's the thing that that
compares the two expressions to see if
they're the same thing without actually
evaluating them but what that's really
doing under the hood is the real
important function of this package is
that to canonical form where it's
converting these things to the to their
canonical representation so they can be
compared and this this is just kind of
the interface to that but like the whole
sandbox evaluation thing lets you do
some pretty neat stuff that you
otherwise would never be able to do for
example you could evaluate these to see
that they reach the same thing if your
computer had enough RAM and you would
survive for however many years that is
they do a value to the same thing
someday but this doesn't need to do that
because of the canonical transformations
and likewise it can tell that if i add
one to the end of their that these are
different it's still going to run to its
time out though because it'll try its
hardest but it's just not going to run
for a thousand years and so this this
basically captures all those different
types of equivalents that i was talking
about first thing it's going to do oh
wow they're supposed to copy not going
to do it
so this is that that first type of
equivalence I was talking about the
inputs exactly the same didn't need to
do anything else saw that immediately I
so it basically will try to do the
simplest thing possible first and it
only resorts these more complicated
methods if necessary so listen for
example that these obviously are not
going to evaluate that's that's a pretty
big number I don't think I have enough
RAM to do that so the second step it
would do that's what I should have done
number two
so that that's the second step
and only if it can't evaluate them to
determine the answer then then it's
going to jump into all this crazy stuff
and you can force it and this is all
stuff that I wasn't going to put my
slides of it oh oh and here this is
actually some VI w ell specific stuff
which in general you probably wouldn't
care about for this kind of package
because there's a lot of visual stuff
that you're asked to generate for the
answers and so for an example like this
you might not care about the inner
structure of the expression because they
look the same on the screen so what what
it does for those types of things
specifically for dawl and no that's
broken on my local version but yeah on
the one that's that's running online
it'll it'll take things like graphics
boxes and things like that and it'll
actually just rasterize them if you
can't figure it out because large
graphics expressions can get pretty
complicated and that would take a really
long time and yeah so this is just stuff
that last two pages of my slides
apparently disappeared but I think I'm
just about out of time anyway okay yeah
so any questions
I have questions
I think it was actually announced in may
I think like at how many submissions and
things like that there last I looked
which is at the data the number of
submissions I think was around hundred
twenty thousand and that's that's all
the expressions are all stored and it
actually one of the things it does is it
tries to find new rules and it's not
fully automated yet and it's something
I've been working on though I basically
wanted to figure out how to improve its
rule system on its own but but it does
search for patterns that would represent
a lot of these types of things people
are doing and to see if it can kind of
tailor itself for this application
specifically but yeah there's a lot of
data
yeah and yep that that does yeah I have
a bunch of verification tests that they
don't run at the time that the users
submitting because I don't want to use
up their five seconds for you know my
self test type of things but afterwards
on the data basically comes through it
and looks for examples where the two
canonical form did not find equivalent
representations but it did evaluate
something equivalent so that's something
that yet that raises a flag that's what
they need to look at because it missed
something so initially in May it was
doing a pretty poor job of finding
things but you're just after like a
couple of weeks of getting a bunch of
these exercises in with that data and
just comparing these patterns and
generating new rules it became pretty
robust when I said I should say that
with a little asterisk because if you
deliberately want to show that it
doesn't work yeah it's it's really easy
to deliberately fool the thing but for
the types of answers that people are
entering if they just want to solve
these exercises it does a pretty good
job I think so at least
well okay
you
[Applause]